Hello Freak bitches.
Like one of the things that is driving me crazy about a lot of this tweeting and
craziness.
Like I was in a New York City for the fights and me and my friend Cam Haines who
went to the gym and young Jamie was there too.
But you weren't with us when we were stuck in the,
in the swarm of humans with just me and cam.
We've got to the gym no problem.
But on our way back,
the protest had marched through the area that we walked through and all of a
sudden we couldn't go anywhere.
It was just jammed with people.
So you're literally shoulder to shoulder with people.
Like just everybody's touching everybody.
There's just,
you had to deal with it.
There was nothing to do with,
which is one of the reasons why a fanny pack is so important folks.
Cause you keep your money in your front.
Okay.
Nobody's pickpocket and I can think zipped up,
my shirt goes over that I'm going to know and to get there,
it's going to take some work cause pickpockets do go to those things you need to
be aware of.
You're one of those super lefties.
It likes to go and castrate you Shit Jack.
So while we're walking this one guy with this perfectly manicured beard,
I'll never forget,
he had a really nice like wool jacket on.
He was,
he was obviously like a wealthy liberal character and he's screaming out.
I mean screaming in my fucking ear.
He's right here.
He's real.
He's touching me,
he's touching me.
The shoulders know Donald Trump.
K,
k.
K.
Racist,
sexist.
But he wouldn't stop.
He wouldn't stop.
And part of me wanting to go,
hey man,
could you just like,
if you want to go in the protest,
the protest is in the street.
Like you're on the sidewalk.
This isn't the protest.
Yeah,
this is the salon.
This is some noncommittal shit you're doing here.
Like if you want to be out in,
he'll be all in.
But he's like,
he's doing drive bys.
He's like a walk by screaming protests.
But does it really do anything?
He saw a black guy and a distance.
I swear to God he starts going shut up.
Black lives matter.
Hell No.
Oh hell.
He's just trying to get everybody to join him with my friend Michael Shermer
likes to call virtue signaling.
That's what it is.
He's peacocking his virtue and just trying,
just trying to get everybody to jump on.
There was a woman with a sign that said Rape Millennia,
Cisa,
and apparently that's about writing that thing out.
Crazy.
Here we go.
It's a Hashtag on Twitter.
Now
look as a,
as a Brit observing what's been happening in America as an outsider,
I'm enormously encouraged by the legalization of cannabis movement that is,
that is taking place here and and,
and what it and what it all means.
Sure.
I liked to smoke a joint,
but this is not about getting high.
It's not about recreation.
What this is about is recognizing the sovereignty of adults to make decisions
over their own bodies,
their own health and their own consciousness while doing no harm to others.
That's what it's about,
and that's a really fucking important issue.
That is for me,
that is the most important issue because if we live in a society that is not
prepared to recognize adults sovereignty over one's own body,
in one's own consciousness,
then that cannot be a free society in any meaningful way.
And so I applaud the people of America in those states who have voted for full
legalization.
That's a brilliant thing to do and that's going to have an impact around the
world because the war on drugs,
all the ideology and lies about cannabis are all going to be proved wrong.
We're going to know that the emperor wears no clothes,
that you can legalize cannabis and civilization does not fall apart as the war
on drugs lobby had been telling us for ages.
It's going to,
it's going to change everything.
And it's a beautiful thing because it's the American people.
Whereas the American state America as a governmental state presence on the world
stage has been the dark force behind the war on drugs.
So it's,
it's uh,
for me a beautiful thing that is the American people's state by state who are
winding that back and saying,
we will not put up with this shit anymore.
I'm not sure.
I think we need to under,
I mean,
the more we figure out about like way a language golf in language,
right?
Um,
there's really,
Jimmy,
if you look,
you might be able to dig it up.
There's a,
there's a guy I want to say is that northern Arizona University who worked on
prairie dog language,
if you have you heard about this,
this is crazy research.
So one of the reasons we've never been able to study animal communication,
and I could screw this up,
but we'll try it,
is we couldn't talk back,
right?
We couldn't talk to them.
So what he did is he recorded it,
ton of prairie dog communication and then started sort of decoding what little
things mean and but use the computer to play it back to them.
So what he discovered is prairie dogs,
which you don't think of it as particularly intelligent.
When they'd started decoding their language,
they started to realize it.
Prairie dogs were teeny say things like,
Hey,
be careful of that right path over there cause there's a fat guy in a purple
sweater coming this way.
That detailed like in the beginning of the [inaudible].
Yeah.
They used to think animals only sort of communicated in like nouns and verbs.
Present tense nouns and verbs,
right.
Snake of the,
you know,
there are some certain calls that are monkeys two days,
right?
The three calls now they're starting to realize they've got adjectives,
they've got tenses.
They can think in the,
for a while they thought animals lived in a perpetual,
pleasant,
present,
right?
Like the argument was all animals are always in flow bright,
which is the every focused,
everything in the now it turns out that's not the case at all.
They have passed,
they have futures.
We asked this question a lot running an animal sanctuary because if we,
if we're caring for a dog,
it's not just older special needs.
It's compromise.
Shelter was on death row is probably if it's ended up with us because we work
with the worst of the worst of the worst.
It's been very,
very badly abused,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And the question my wife and I always used to talk about was do they know,
do they like,
do they feel grateful to us?
Do they,
can they remember their past enough to know that,
you know,
the present is different and we were,
we were,
what was different?
Like those kinds of questions.
And after,
you know,
10 12 years of doing this work,
hard core,
I think they really know and I think,
you know,
they live in a,
in a timescale that's a lot broader than we've given them credit for.
When you do see
all this stuff on TV,
one thing that you can't deny,
it might not affect you and it might not affect me,
but there are certain people that fall the tone of the leaders of this country.
And when you have a guy who's the president who you know is going to say
insulting,
should call John Stewart a pussy and an in a tweet at one 30 in the morning,
like that sets the tone for the country and it's going to make some people very
happy.
There's some people that love to talk shit they loved and salt people on the
like,
fuck yeah,
open season.
The way I described it,
I said political correctness took a missile to the dick cause that's what it was
like.
He's like,
this is the,
this is the guy at the top of the totem pole and we,
we can relax our standards now and all the things that have been annoying you,
but people nitpicking about behaviors and insults and you know,
safe words and safe spaces and all that stuff's Kinda gone.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
yeah.
So it does affect the way people think and behave right there.
There's almost nobody who won't use the word Pussy in public there.
Do you remember so many months ago when that just wasn't a thing?
That's so true.
You couldn't say that.
That's so drew.
It became like a constant like dinner table talk.
Like people sit around and talk at saint grabbed the busy.
Yeah.
It's got to be from women.
That's how it got even better.
My girlfriend said it's true.
It's so true.
That is so true.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I think that we go one way and we go to the other and I think that people get
tired of too much left and they want some.
Right.
And I think that's why we went from Carter to Reagan.
That's why we went from Bush to Clinton.
I just think that's what we do,
I think is what we've always done.
Okay.